okay so here we are this is eating your
feed a show where our for an atom
challenges us to recreate some of the
most viral foods from the internet today
we also have our friend Annie behind
camera we've actually done this before
we have and it's been a lot of fun so
today on eating your feed we're gonna be
making this cheeseburger but the cheese
is a sauce that gets dumped on top
liquid cheese as always we have Rhea
who's tasty producer chef extraordinaire
Andrea and I are not experts but we try
very hard so this is called the cheese
bomb at a restaurant in London called
maxwell's it's kind of getting close to
one of my other fantasies savory cereal
what a cheesy porridge that had little
hamburgers floating in it oh yeah what
is your plan for making this melty
cheese I don't know I was gonna look it
up I don't know melty cheese something
called a roux yeah like bechamel oh
really
all right let's get ingredients thanks
ray buttermilk flour to me comforting
blah blah blah mature cheddar cheese no
cheese that's the kind of cheese we'll
get Adam just said isn't a bechamel plus
cheese a mornay do you have a preference
on what kind of burger you'd like to
make I prefer I never says he wants a
thick patty style thick patty style is
my specialty I also like putting avocado
on bagels
no fine get off the car don't care we're
in California whatever yeah we can do
this let's go get this cheese it's a
little treat for later brioche
it's $12 a pound that's been tested so
here our gross is beef butter yellow
cheddar cheese white cheddar cheese and
backup cheese that Adam made us get
oranges cuz they're delicious and in
season it's exceedingly regular Avogadro
brioche buns buns onions because we're
gonna caramelize some onions for our
burger thick-cut bacon well how thick
that is so thick some fries
then tomatoes and some lettuce to top
our burger with I think we're gonna make
the cheese sauce first how does this
work
Wow what are you doing I don't know I
just have to keep pressing it until
something happens this is a crumbly
cheddar you're a crumbly cheddar were
melting butter stop eating it all
saucepan mmm I don't recommend and we
use warm milk but I forgot and now Adams
up making the brew so we're gonna go at
this Merrill that looks good she sucks
and we had cheese to this bechamel
that's amore
cuz it's a more a sauce you guys I don't
hear any laughs get some more name-o so
I'm just gonna keep stirring this until
it gets thick and then we'll add the
cheese stir it until it's thick that's
what I just said adding the cheese is so
much fun I'm having a hard time stopping
I think we definitely got the right
texture texture oh I shouldn't maybe you
cut these my cry let's add the onions
before the photo burg let's make her ger
patties so vibrant
you think doctors ever are like any
doctor thank you doctor no because that
would make them not sterile sometimes
when I cook onions at home like a lot of
them my cat walking in the kitchen will
be like I actually need to change this
go up because I touched the floor you
touch the floor patty patty your burgers
are gargantuan these are Nikki's those
are mine
I like to make a lot of sounds were like
take a minute no I'm doing great where's
my coffee we got bacon and we got fries
do are you put everything in your mouth
I'm going to bake my bacon how thick
that is is the oven preheated your Eisen
already your fries the fries I'm gonna
go put my bacon in the oven
he's so salty today do you think these
onions are almost done Theodore you keep
going I like them to talk juicy tomato
what beautiful produce the drownin
cheese it's look very crisp the bacon
has become bacon got a crisp but it's
still jiggly good job Oh smells good
we've probably toasters button the same
thing actually yeah gets me on this nice
that's a nice-looking burger being that
away from the fire alarm please aren't I
just under this air mom yeah
the lettuce is on the bottom and I'm
gonna put the avocado underneath that
okay
onions alright I'm coming in with a
bacon strip yeah let's top her off you
ready to jar up our cheese sauce yes
yeah I mean our burger looks really good
yeah I wouldn't be really excited to eat
that regardless yeah even if it didn't
have a giant jug of cheese on the side
so we brought rehave a create look at
what we did already just look like the
video yeah good job she's getting not so
warm anymore we ready this port slowly
not gonna use all the cheese okay here
we go
Oh Go Go
Oh are we still eating it must be good
why ma'am I guess sloppy seconds here we
go
nothing great brother
[Music]
nailed it
I wonder what else we can choose I think
we should make some more and then she's
mother's stuff all right no lumps no
lumps no lumps
oh we have a smorgasbord to cover with
cheese we have three more burgers we
have a slice of lasagna meatballs
chicken wings and Brussels sprout for
our vegetarian friends on our dessert
plate we have some burnt marshmallows
Pizza chocolate bunny ice cream peanut
girl we invited some of our friends
ready yeah
okay guys come on in alright ready
[Applause]
we're gonna do some more experiments you
want some lasagna
are you putting cheese on this ice cream
we're about to okay so today we made a
delicious liquid cheese sauce it's good
on some things better on others it's
terrible on some I think we nailed this
cheese sauce I think we got pretty close
to the restaurants rendition of the
burger I think so covered with cheese I
think we finally answered the question
today
is there such thing as too much cheese
yeah oh yes
[Music]